[Music]
hey guys and welcome to our mass effect
andromeda live stream i'm chasti this is
all brought to you by dell gaming today
i have a special guest this is greg
miller from kind of funny what's up
everybody are you ready to see how this
mass effect andromeda patch is going to
work i sure am patch jay what's up very
exciting thanks for being here please
it's a pleasure i'm so glad it finally
worked out because i've seen a lot of
the internet commenters yeah my people
in the twitch chat right now because
we're on twitch.tv such kind of funny
games we are well as game spots game
spots youtube spots twitch people are
like you know what why are you doing
this why are you doing this yeah i mean
while i was doing mass effect mornings
when mass effect came out yeah it became
zelda mornings which then i was like oh
i'm playing more mass effect then the
patch got announced then you guys were
talking about hey can you come over and
do this with us come on i was like yes
it got delayed it got delayed to patch
day we get to see what patch does now
let's see the patch it's patch 1.05 so
we're going to see what kind of
improvements we have they promised that
they're going to fix some eyes some lip
syncing and they're going to be able to
skip some
i think when you go to different
galaxies you're able to skip those
animations now wonky right yeah flying
around having to watch everybody do
you're like why i would do that that's
right you're on youtube damien pinakuyo
i can't pronounce your last name
gamespot gave this game a score of 60.
why streaming there's new patches new
patch news don't you want to see if
these asari faces look better i do want
to see that and we're also playing on
the alienware 13 gaming laptop which we
will be showing to you a bit later but
for now we're jumping right into the
game
they were talking about ryder eventually
with the zigzags getting fixed correct
incorrect yes
so
are the ladies
let's see if those zigzag running
animations are fixed so far the zigzag's
looking better it's looking good that is
a fine zigzag you know what i mean i
don't know if that was different
what's your rating on this zigzag run
right now so far a 60 why are they
streaming
so how much how much mass effect have
you played not a lot yeah uh because i
was kind of waiting for this patch
because i was hearing what everyone else
was saying and with zelda and with
persona 5. sure i was like i'm just
going to wait you know i'm going to wait
for this big old patch and we got this
patch like an hour ago so luckily this
worked out quite nicely and we're able
to see all the new animations and all
the fixes for this so
looking forward to that and i think i'll
probably start playing more now i
started playing and then i put it down
in favor of playing zelda 100 well that
was the problem with me too whereas i
when i got it i was like yes more mass
effect yes i want to play it yeah
jumping into and playing it was like all
right this is good but like uh
it's not great and when you're going up
again when there's when we have a
stacked spring like we have where there
is a horizon there is zelda there's for
honor if you're that kind of gamer
there's near there it's like well and
then finally persona came yeah and
that's the thing when persona comes
persona put everything else down
i put down zelda to play persona see now
i was so close to the end of zelda i was
like i gotta commit and i was like i was
gonna do the thing where this you know
the switch is gonna be switch is gonna
be my on the road game so that's where
and i have to worry about it there but
even then it started bleeding over we
started doing mass effect mornings and
then we had a whole bunch of crashes and
kids were like just play zelda i was
like you know what kids you're right i
will just listen to the kids speaking of
the kids we are hanging out with all of
you on chat if you want to get a
question in for greg or for me or about
anything in general about mass effect
ask on youtube or twitch for gamespot so
we are on the gamespot channels
unfortunately i don't have access to the
kind of funny greg does that right now
but greg does look i'm looking right
there hey joey noel hey doctor board x
hi guys
okay yeah yeah there's something in
there
yeah so we'll be answering those
questions um i'm monitoring all the chat
on i am too commander james shepherd
says she loves greggy she's a big fan of
oh that's so nice thank you very much
hello i love the screen you guys have
over there because like when kevin does
our chat for twitch it's just kevin is
lazy he just throws up the chat oh yeah
oh that's all you do kevin's terrible
he's the worst he just throws it up
there heard it here first kevin's
terrible exactly i actually have never
met him i'm sure he's lovely i don't
know yeah no he is very good he's the
glue that holds it all together over
there
well i can't wait to meet her exuberant
one just got here youtube and she he or
she says greg is this post patch this is
postpartum we're looking at sorry faces
everybody check out these faces take a
look at these facial animations and take
a look at these eyes this is what they
have changed so human eyes are different
let's look at the lip sync we're
studying it study it real close
everybody
i mean the face is still gonna look
great right but the lipstick's better
sure yeah there's a slight improvement
here yeah like i don't
feel like i want to punch myself in the
face watching the exams
here's the thing about it when i was
playing it pre-patch on playstation 4
where it looks decidedly worse than it
does the pc version was the fact of the
matter yeah do they look great no do i
really care not really it's just
good yeah how many masterpieces have
been released this year you know what i
mean
the voice acting is good is what i meant
to say okay
well now here's the thing i've been
playing as male writer
i like male right
yeah looks like i'm just using default
because i like the defaults this time
around looks like nathan drake sounds
like nolan north
and i'm not i'm not saying that's a
problem i'm just saying i gave mine guy
liner
you give him guideline yeah yeah he
looks like he plays for fallout boy now
yes exactly or panic at the disco take
your pick man question on twitch hey
greg what's for lunch
i don't know what we're gonna do for
lunch we're gonna here's the point some
lunch i'm downtown on second street used
to work at a business downtown on second
street sure did pretty sure they closed
they just couldn't live out without me
uh
they had a place across from ign called
american subs which i love the best the
best subs you know what i mean yeah and
then merrigan went out of business i
assumed because i wasn't there to eat
there anyway it's now sage which is i
think
i don't
let's see what's going on over in chat
greg where do you think mass effect goes
from here
i think they keep building on this i
think i mean i think that
we're being
the problem with mass effect andromeda
is the fact that they had such a weird
release plan and a weird review plan
that it's out there and so everybody's
just making fun of the gifts and doing
different things but mass effect 1 had a
lot of problems mass effect 1 though we
didn't have much to compare it to sure
so like the elevator rides that we would
have been gifted and put up and like
made fun of non-stop would have been a
bigger deal the awkward impression with
the series the first your first you know
the way they all moved and animated mass
effect would have been made fun of if
that was where we were but now
when you put mass effect on something
there's a lineage there and there's an
expected bar of quality
and so to get here and not have that i
think that this is going to inspire them
to work harder for the next thing i
think this is going to be another
trilogy i think they're thinking that
long term on it i think bioware knows
what this is and they also know that
like mass effect's mass effect sure it's
it didn't deliver on people's hopes and
dreams for andromedas you know first
impression however it's sold yeah and
it's gonna sell more merch it's gonna do
other things and the thing about it is
the hardest massive heart the hardest of
the hardcore mass effect fans i know are
all talking about i enjoyed it it just
wasn't you know it wasn't mass effect 2
it wasn't this instant classic sure
so what are we doing right now we're
doing a loyalty mission oh yeah i'm
doing cora's loyalty
that is what we're doing right now if
you're wondering we're not getting a lot
of things out jesse yes so again we're
knocking out how does the patch look
then i had stopped before i got to
loyalty missions because i was like
they're going to patch this right they
didn't just wait and then it was so then
kids have been asking me what do i think
of the loyalty missions in the story and
stuff i don't have anything to say well
here you go after today i will yeah i'll
be able to say
i want to shoot things in the head yep i
think someone asked over in chat talk
about the patch differences all right so
i've got some patch notes right here and
they said they're improving tutorial
placement increased inventory limits
single player balance changes ammo
crates armor weapons nomad profiles
attacks progression multiplayer balance
changes improved matchmaking and latency
and multiplayer there's a whole bunch of
stuff going on here but we're most
interested in seeing those uh lip sync
and facial acting
different stuff sorry here we go
what do you got for me cora rescuers the
faces do a little bit humans look a
little bit better i think someone over
on the youtube chat said the eyes look
better to them yeah they do yeah
because they were
i love the patch over on youtube
greg is the combat better how long we're
about to find out we're about to find
out because you know how much that was a
lot of talkie-talkie and a lot of shitty
shooting then a lot of sexy sexy
maybe hopefully i hope you get yourself
i'll see where we get look at our
see hair else do we have in here so
eventually we'll have to check out and
see uh the difference when you are going
in the galaxy map and how we can just
skip those
sequences it's worth pointing out this
isn't my survival we're playing we're
playing on this
i want to point out whoever saved this
is how much i like their rider color
scheme on their costume oh i went with
the kind of funny blue and it just
doesn't look right
but what i like here
yeah i mean you can do anything with the
character you can make it look however
you want we can even make a character
later and see
how that looks
it's up to you let's see how far we get
in this loyalty mission
and we'll also take a look at the
alienware 13 a little bit later and show
that off to you
which actually looks really good right
now the game looks great on the screen
sure well i mean that i mean that's the
thing about when i first played mass
effect andromeda i played it at uh the
preview event down to ea played it on
the pc and i came back and i was like oh
man it looks really good so then when i
got on playstation 4 i was like
[Laughter]
goddammit they got us again well it's
looking pretty sweet on pc right now
especially after this patch
all right let's answer some questions
over in chat so we are on twitch and
youtube game spots channels and that's
what i'm looking at right now
let's see what kind of questions we have
yes it is the 1.05 patch if you're
wondering if you're just tuning in this
is the patched version
the one that fixes it all yep hopefully
this is the one that takes it from a six
to a ten
when is craig gonna take off his shirt
this is a family show so not today i'll
do that i'm kind of funny go to
california
i got kind of funny for that sorry guys
i gotta you gotta hold something back
right you gotta put some content behind
uh behind the wall
yes
is mass effect and dead space the same
universe no no
no it's not that'd be a fun crosstalk
yeah
someone said scorpio is so disappointing
i actually we were prepping for this and
i have no idea what's going on i mean
it's exactly i mean it's exactly what we
all were thinking it was going to be
where they were like hey here are all
these great stacks and i'm just like i'm
not that guy i am the guy who's like
well it looks worse on playstation but
i'll play it right you know what i mean
like if they're like here it is the most
powerful console i'm like well we knew
that was gonna happen
i mean i don't know it's one of those i
wish everybody well but again like i'm
the guy who built a career on
playstation and i didn't buy playstation
4 pro i was like i'm not the target
audience for this so like
when they're like hey it's a souped-up
xbox i'm like well i only turn on xbox
one
four times a year maybe for exclusives
or when for some reason i can't do hbo
go
on playstation so that sucks yeah hbo go
on my xbox
well the big problem was for the
playstation for longest time for us out
here is that comcast didn't play nice
with it and now they found a patch of
that there it is
patches for patches hey greg how are you
today over on twitch i'm good i like
that i'm here playing games good this is
the big the big thing about what we do
is that i you know when we left and we
started doing our own [ __ ] i was like i
want to play games all the time on
camera be great and then we never have
time to do that
so when i started the mass effect
morning thing a couple weeks ago that
was fun and then it was like right back
to all right nick scarpino cracking the
whip now you really got to do this i
think i want to do that he's like you
got to do it i can't do it
so now him and tim i got to hold the
morning show right after this
yep
yeah right
you can watch the kind of funny morning
show yes you can i twist not even 20
games
they'll talk about scorpio plug yes they
will they're going to bring in that andy
cortez fellow we just hired because he
knows all about video games
all about those video games that's right
i like this sort this uh weapon i got
too
who's saved with this combat is still
fun someone said way better than m-e-1
sure now dem says will i platinum this
game yeah correctly platinum this game
not a chance at house i'm to the point
that i'm worried about getting back to
because that's what i do all the time
with video games of like oh i'm i'm
jumping to this i'm going to worry about
that and like now that i'm
20 hours into persona or whatever and
it's like oh that's how i love people
get out of there
what am i i want to get back to this
even like right now playing i'm like all
right i you know i enjoy this yeah i
caught up and like
the problem when we talk about things we
love is that i feel like in the video
games yes we get so hung up on the
negatives all the time with facial
animation you forget the fact i'm like
well i like the story and i like where
it's going yeah i like the comments it's
fun the combat's fun and the animations
the planets look great like yeah there's
a lot to like yeah about something else
it's just funny you know um
we'll start talking [ __ ] about the kids
it's funny because
when what was it fallout 4 got released
uh colin moriarty when he was still kind
of funny go support collins last stance
uh talked about the fact that you know
fallout 4 was clearly made in a vacuum
where they went away made it and then
they came back like oh everything's
changed right the wishers come out now
this is what an open people expect more
from open worlds right i think it's the
same thing with matt's like especially
coming off of zelda where it was like oh
we're going to hold your hand and direct
you everywhere you need to go here right
but like
this is not where we are anymore
i like that it's a mix like you've got a
few open worlds here that you go to just
drive around well that was the cool
thing about like you know i in my my uh
my play forum i saved at home you know
i've knocked out eos where it was went
there and like that was one when you
finish that first mission like there are
now the plan is yours like do you want
to you know worry about making it this
knew that i was like oh okay
okay i can do that okay yeah sure
you know the more i look at this the
more it has improved yeah yeah yeah and
i feel like i would jump back into this
i mean and that's you know hats off i
mean like again if we want to be the
negative nancy's about everything yeah
we want to sit here and just be mean to
everybody like a lot in the game ship
complete blah blah great questions yeah
it is but again at least
bioware is not abandoning it which
matters you know what i mean they are
sitting there being like we understand
that we screwed this up and we're gonna
come in and we're gonna do different
things this isn't the only patch they
will be rolling out more patches so
eventually we'll get to a point where
there's a lot to offer sure
well the content's already there right
it's just i mean yeah how are we gonna
make it not be a laughing stock but the
problem is of course that you can't once
that genie is out of the bottle you
can't put it back in when people think
mass effect andromeda they're gonna
think of it's like uh it's like
assassin's creed right the one where
like there was no faces and it was like
it was like some weird stat of like yeah
you know ten percent of all pc players
are getting this but that's what
everybody thinks i want to think of
syndicate or what no unity unity right
unity was the one and it was like all
right cool and everybody forgets about
that game then that's just a ride off of
a joke
yep but mass effect fans they'll know
about this pitch blacked out forever
watch your step oh man they still didn't
remove the default idle smile from
female rider
yeah it's fine
[Music]
what color scheme is your armor uh i
actually it's it's not that different i
kind of like the way that it looked so i
didn't really change it i just kind of
changed his hair and gave him something
that was this
what is this
wait what do we have to do here
nothing it's just
it's just like some kind of weird it
says check this out
that's the pathfinder who died it's an
honor oh
rip why'd you do that that's just
disrespectful no it's my way of honoring
one pathfinder to another in the air oh
my god
don't shoot the castle don't you
apologize
we're about 15 minutes in if you're just
tuning in we are playing mass effect
andromeda thanks to our friends over at
dell gaming we're playing on the
alienware 13 and we've got greg miller
here from kind of funny hi hello i'm
sorry i like i like reading the emails a
lot nick scarpino and me argue about
this all the time you read the emails in
the game oh yeah
well i mean like for me mass effect's
all world building right so i want to
know what's going on because that's like
for me
you know doing me wrong yeah last of us
is amazing in environmental storytelling
because it kind of like wrote stuff on
the walls you'd find these tattered
pieces like in space the emails make
sense i want to know what's going on one
of the most endearing moments i thought
for me so far in mass effect early on is
when i got to walk around tempest for
the first time and i started going
through like the crew uh you know like
quarters and reading their emails and
it's them just bullshitting around about
like what's going on here and like who's
gonna do this and don't leave your stuff
out i was like oh you know what that's
really that's cool yeah i like that now
now i feel like i know you guys i'm
actually
my girl though pb is dope i love pb
if you want to ask a question to greg
about the patch or about
mass effect andromeda we are on twitch
and youtube we're answering questions
from gamespot's channels and i think
greg has access to i got the kind of
funny kind of funny one open so woody
allen says press f to disrespect
emergency alarms
how are you personally um oh my god i'm
only five hours in oh heartbreaking yeah
it's only when i have free time and
i just got it last night was one of
those things eight o'clock on tuesday
and i was waiting by my door and
amazon's at eight o'clock and luckily
they showed up right at eight nice it's
weird i've had it cut that so close
lately when kevin ordered his
playstation vr it was yeah it came like
right it's like 750. and then i think i
got my uh take your heart collection
edition of persona yeah at something
like yeah 6 30 right now nice i should
have bought that i was just being cheap
i couldn't not do it yeah i was like i i
was like if i if it turns out i don't
love morgana i'll return it or i want
okay
i love morgana that's what i'm saying i
like morgana what the hell are you guys
doing in here
someone said looks like destiny
i kind of can get that i get that vibe
the blues and like these guys in their
armor yeah
good luck are you now are you a destiny
player jason no but i'm going to jump
into destiny 2 when it comes out did you
play any destiny one
okay i played it if i played and i got
to like when it was vanilla yeah i got
to level 25 or whatever enjoyed myself
fine came back for a little bit of the
wolves content uh yeah i'm i'm
interested to see what they make
change-wise for destiny 2 seeing how
they're talking about the fact that it's
supposed to be more open to everybody
but give you know hardcore players what
they want to do yeah
i can go for more
if i'm being honest uh i love that
better division
no big deal not bragging just like
[Music]
why does a whole new galaxy only have
two new races excellent question
commander it's slowly i mean what if
somebody came to our galaxy there'd be
one race
you're saying right human race unless
we're counting our animals animals
creatures well then are the wraith the
wraith aren't like cats are they i don't
know sure i'm not that deep into the war
in mass effect
someone on youtube said are lips fixed
too and movement in cinematics
um the lips seem to be working
a little bit better
yeah the
lipstick
the lip syncing looks a little bit
better
i don't it's one of those this whole
thing with the patching process is going
to be baby stuff yes like i think i
think yeah i think it does look better
i've seen people in chat saying it looks
better too and they're probably more
versed in it than i am uh but i think
you don't come in thinking like no here
we go yeah everything's fixed
everything's perfect hey guys do you
think we will get a patch to improve the
cover system
that's an interesting one have you used
enough of the cover system to have an
opinion no i'm not i like the old cover
system better i like click to cover this
whole like
you know uh i didn't really have
contextual much of a problem with it but
it's just it just i don't i
like the gears of war
i know what i'm doing i know that i'm
slamming in here i'm making a choice
rather than having to rely on the game
because there always is that thing of
like well
that screw up because of me or because
of the game right
yeah i usually blame myself first wow
that's a cool grenade that is pretty
nice wow
it's also nice playing with the save
because i play as a soldier yeah theory
i just put all my things into assault
rifles and pistols so to have all these
new boxes
yep good stuff good stuff take cover you
idiots get down what is that
thank you for listening oh you sound
goddamn sorry
so stubborn such a stubborn race
such a stuffer that makes me racist i
don't think i'm allowed to say that
over there
waluigi is in mass effect wow yes yes
we are over on twitch and youtube
checking out chat let's see
enemy variety needs work in my opinion
yeah
i could agree with that
a lot of the same yeah
but they're all just bodies right
they're all just grunts they're all just
foot soldiers
yup yup
so what are alienware specs what are the
settings you guys are playing yeah
good question we're gonna be talking
about
yeah no we're gonna be talking about
this laptop a little bit later but it
has the nvidia geforce gtx 1060. how is
the arcade's fire control
so there it is let's try again
here we go they fixed the animations
patch 1.05 ah
i don't know we haven't seen one yet the
zigzag we are not confirming or denying
if it looks better or worse yes
they got me back but i'm okay i'm
looking at the patch notes to see if
there was any mention of that but i'm
not seeing it well
they do you're able to skip the
autopilot sequences i don't know if they
fixed the sequences
improved logic timing continuity for
relationships and story arcs
various collision issues are fixed thank
god because the collision issues that
was really the one yeah i feel sometimes
like
writing passion suck
yeah here's what this is i mean that's
why playstation firmware is always just
like
improved stability on some playstations
and streaming and stability improvements
supposedly so that's good
more emails there we go
calm still there's no emails doing this
the old-fashioned way we cannot finish
the evac with deck 12 in that condition
that last cat barrage seared the whole
plating no atmosphere and it's hanging
by a thread i've got 100 people trapped
on the other side and not enough suits
there's children that's a bad time i
can't make the call i won't oh no we
must help
see i'm that's what i'm talking about
you got to read don't you want to know
what went wrong on this video i do i
want to know what you want to see in
this stuff how are you liking the
loyalty mission this is your first one
so far so good i already liked core a
lot cora is one of the
was one i don't think there's anybody
actually so far that i've met because i
was really surprised too playing this
game how early i got i popped the trophy
for your whole crew yeah like i popped
it like in six five hours whatever i was
like that's weird but uh okay the one
guy who kind of looks like a cobra if
you imagine garrus matched up with a
cobra and he's got the weird like dragon
ball z i think
i'm not sold on him yet but he's still
new
core though pb what up this is the crew
quincy brown's my dad all right i like
sex i like clancy brown
clan's friend's great pbc
what is it
it's like
looks like an observation deck
for observing the message question on
youtube do you think this game is better
than mass effect 3 no no
the pro i mean i always talk about it
like mass effect 3
throw away let's no we're not going to
argue about the ending sure
mass effect 3
is a cheat because mass effect 2 was so
good so coming in with those same guys
and just continuing off with that cast
of characters and stuff great mass
effect 1 total disappointment when i
said it no one ever wants to say it i'll
say it
wasn't that great it would help fast
track two shots
i wish more maps were in multi-players
on youtube why are you playing
multiplayer
why migraine why
you don't need to play people like
multiple players thank god there's about
14 000 other games that play on
multiplayer don't worry about it play
titanfall nothing
oh someone said hey i just subscribed
because of you two oh thank you
to me or them yeah thank you
thank you
thank you also greg but no thank you
more
thank you
someone said i've never played mass
effect i do not have a good pc well you
can probably get yourself an alienware
13 and then play it on that no like what
you did there oh my goodness
sliding in the sponsor
[Laughter]
i also don't like this ammo pickup thing
they got going on yeah it's just like i
don't do i need it do i not need it i'm
gonna run to them to see if i need it if
anything
would be like this jump this biotic jump
he's gone
i like that ready vadaria it's good
someone said the story sucks dude what
do you think of the story this story the
story yeah i mean again super early i
like where it's at i like it
take cover oh my god it's the big gun
uh story wise i think it's a really cool
idea we've gone into ayax and we need to
figure everything out again i do think
it's kind of weird that you know it kind
of looks like our guy you know i mean
it's not it doesn't look super foreign
whatever but in terms of like hey this
is what the story is and do this that's
fine and then hey we're going to keep
bouncing around i think i think the
group comes together too quickly i think
it's interesting oh no run away
i think it's weird every speaks english
except the cat for something you know
okay
but again i'm early in it so i don't
know if it gets bad later on
someone said so how does how dad locked
my memories not a family someone said
how do i subscribe to greg over on kind
of funny yeah there you go go to kind of
funny's channel youtube.com kind of
funny kind of funny game have a good
time twitch.tv kind of funny game we'll
be on right after this with the morning
show yup
i won't be there
it's okay because he's going to get food
yeah that's gonna be great what are we
getting for lunch
it's your choice i don't know anything
around here there's italian food there's
all sorts of food there's different
types of asians there's some kind of new
pizza place down where uh the other
sandwich shop used to be isn't it it's
like have you not been
like buy any boxes
we'll figure it out first we must defend
god damn it
oh no
i feel like that wouldn't protect you
very much it's got holes yeah right
they're just gonna go straight through
the hole oh look it blew up
so if you're just checking this out we
are playing a loyalty mission this is
loyalty quora
thing is floating away yep what a living
nightmare
[Music]
and we are playing the newly patched
mass effect andromeda this is patch 1.05
we've got greg miller here from kind of
funny hi and we're hanging out on
youtube and
twitch so ask questions
we're getting lunch suggestions in the
chat
[Laughter]
what are they saying rooster and rice
which is a really good chicken place is
it down here too it is it's right behind
me but now i'm hungry too
that's all i've had is this iced tea
because i'm not a i'm not a morning
person oh really i'm a total morning i
have it down where i eat the yogurt when
i get to work that's true i usually eat
when i get to work but i was playing
persona last night and then i went to
sleep and then got up and did this nice
hooray
can we talk more about persona
we could talk a little bit more about
christmas who who is best girl
i don't know yet because i that you know
persona is the exact opposite of
i've played 20 hours i have
four i won two companions there were a
lot more uh three more
but yeah i didn't i gotta i'm not gonna
commit that early you know what i mean
because i got that take your heart
edition yeah i'm i'm looking at the box
it has all the characters on there i'm
like there are a lot of girls in here
i'm going to choose best girl if you've
got a best girl let us know in the chat
because i'm still undecided because i've
only met like two girls so far
and if you're playing mass effect and
drama and you've seen any of the patch
yet it's it's new so this is probably
your first time seeing it let us know
what you think of the patch or let us
know what you think of what you see
right now on your screen
is it better is the zigzag running
formation better to you
yes or no
zigzag is bad
please fix
let's check out what's going on over in
chat
oh someone said persona 5 is my first
anything i need to know oh i think you
can you can play persona 5 as your first
show
jump in enjoy it get immersed in it uh
mike mccarty this is his first persona
as well and he's really enjoying it um i
think it's a it's a fine entry into the
internet a fine entry
no yeah you'll be fine jumping right in
don't worry about it just jump in and
play don't look at guys don't worry
about stuff you're not gonna like you
know how goldfarb is putting up all
these tips on his like here's how i'd
flatten them or how i plant them and
it's all like but same every other day
and dude you don't have to worry about
that jump in there playing make your
choices he platinumed it on both the
japanese versions in the english version
i don't know how that happened but he
did it oh i'll tell you how it is
[Laughter]
tell us how you feel about the game and
the patch over on chat let's see what's
going on in chat someone said what a
wonderful game
it's fun it's fun
someone asks what are the specs of the
laptop we're gonna get into that and
show you some b-roll right after this so
stay tuned and i will let you know
but this is the alienware 13. thanks for
asking
what's the best persona question
i always like jack frost but i mean i've
just been around him a long long time i
think they meant the game oh my
apologies i thought you meant
[Music]
um i mean i it's super early for me but
i could easily see five becoming the
best one for me i think so too like i'm
only five hours in but
i
really took a liking to it immediately
and i love i just love everything about
it sure it's so much fun even like the
menus are so stylish i was like wow
when i saw it for the first time here in
the gamespot office and i couldn't play
noise but it's gosh i love that game
yeah that's the thing about it i think
where it's such a great culmination of
everything they've learned granted i've
only been playing persona since persona
3. so persona 3
uh persona 3 portable persona 4 persona
4 golden and now persona 5. but the
having ranged weapons again having you
know all these different things the hd
the style of it the
stuff i can't tell you about you play
dancing all night i did play dancing all
night yeah that was fun yeah it was a
good time
that's when i knew goldfarb was on
another level so he flattened him back
before it came out too in japanese
question you see what has changed with
the patch
funny you should ask uh we mentioned it
before but if you're just tuning in we
there's some bug fixes and improvements
to the player experience so they got a
number of balance changes to single
player and multiplayer resolved some
issues with saves not working properly
they improved lip sync and facial acting
during summer conversations they've
implemented the much requested change to
allow players to skip the autopilot
sequences in the galaxy map and they
have full patch notes up on their blog
but yeah that's what we're looking at
that zigzag run got fixed
that's what we were all really hung up
on that was the big one we were
confused so yeah someone did mention
that she looked kind of dead in the face
before and she looks a little more
lively now the eyes look better yeah
they did my eyes do look better
but now then i but here's my thing when
you get into this kind of thing where
it's like okay they say in the notes we
fix the eyes whatever yeah how much do
they really change is it now just that
implanted suggestion yes but now i'm
looking for these ideas i can see the
difference i was watching a lot of
animations last night and i'm pretty
sure it looks different to me or i'm
just tired
and everything looks great on this
alienware screen
but yeah it looks good so far
even if i can't save
also multiplayer balance changes
single-player balance changes
and they've let's see decrease the cost
of remnant decryption keys so there's
that improved logic timing continuity
for relationships and story arcs
all sorts of things
guardian of temples
are their faces still tired we were just
talking about that that's not that bad
it's a little bit better carissa was
forced to choose between her pathfinder
someone said you can pick it up cheap
now well worth it in my opinion yeah if
you're gonna if you haven't played the
game yet
you might as well do it now like you
feel good about waiting because now
there's a patch
what do i do it's an interesting
argument though right you're talking
about earlier like at least bioware
hasn't abandoned it but then it is that
thing of like well how do as an early
adopter is the biggest mass effect fan
like you know i look at like andrea
renee like she was tweeting about it
like
i put like you know dozens and dozens i
think she's something like seven hours
you know that's great that they're
fixing it but i kind of feel like
why didn't i get this right do you feel
like
someone that's put in 70 hours of time
wasted their time not wasting it but it
is it is that back to that argument and
what's so hard about game development of
like yeah all right cool like how how do
you fix this situation right and you did
not i'm not gonna say screw over people
but you did put out a game that isn't up
to the standards they wanted and clearly
not up to the standards the developer
wanted either yeah and so like now they
go and they fix it but it's like
how does that make it feel if you did
buy it on launch day and you did play
through it you did it you know what i
mean it's similar to like even with
persona 5 right now where they're doing
this whole like nobody streamed the game
don't stream after july please like what
are you talking about
you can't say that like and then they're
clearly gonna have to dial that back at
some point yeah and when they do what
does that mean for the people who
already passed and already had their
opinion made up so if you did put 70
hours in you think the game looked like
crap and now it's like no no the game
looks great now it's just like well
what have you done for me lately you
didn't do it for me when i needed it
question on youtube is there anyone who
still loves ps vita you can go to hell
wearing the vita island shirt you know
that i love vida everybody loves you
yeah i still play dancing all night on
my view really yeah it's cool once in a
while i just got some video game i'm
gonna bring to the plane tomorrow the
mass effect field device unless i get
mario kart good ol vita times i still
haven't gotten a switch you are crazy i
am playing i'm playing zelda on wii u oh
yeah dude
the thing is i didn't
i didn't play anything on my wii u and i
needed to justify my purchase somehow no
way man that was that was my thing
that's why i was so proud to just toss
the wii u on the ground like i hate you
and i never have to touch you again
bring every bring every great wii u game
to the switch i don't care yeah that'd
be great it'd be great
these guys put down some smoker
i don't like that one thing someone said
i'm sort of disappointed i put in 485
hours before the patch but that's just
what happens i guess yeah video games
right i mean that's the whole thing i
mean the argument becomes
with video games
if you're if we feel that way i guess
you should wait forever right because
every game is going to have a patch
every game every game is going to be on
sale every game is going to be
bargaining eventually
definitive editions game of the years
like that happens so it's like you don't
have to play it when it comes out
yeah especially this year when there's
so much to catch up on i still haven't
played horizon zero oh my god who are
you because of zelda i had to spend a
lot on the wii u nowhere no oh whatever
my life's a mess besides the people i'm
glad you can admit it at least you can
admit you made very wrong decisions i i
mean i was trying to fight spiders in my
bathroom last night so my life was a
mess
and i couldn't go in my bathroom
after that because there were two of
them so what happened was i saw one by
the toilet threw a bath mat at it
and then it didn't die and i was like
well crap and then now he's pissed now
he knows we're in a fight i look up and
i see his spider friend like looking at
me and he saw everything so i'm pretty
sure like i just keep playing out all
these like kill bill scenarios in my
head sure and so when i woke up this
morning i went to the bathroom and there
sure enough spider hanging over the
toilet like i've been expecting you
please have a seat he's like we've been
watching we know what you do and i was
like well i guess i am going to the
bathroom at work so
there's that do you not have like a
broom very excited
uh
i do i just didn't think about it
i was thinking in the heat of the moment
i didn't think of a broom did
contemplate burning my house
tell me your worst spider stories over
on youtube and twitch
and we'll talk about it and commiserate
thank you mine was in columbia missouri
i had graduated
spider story yeah my sweater story all
right uh graduated college was live in
my first place afterwards
i came home from work one day at the
newspaper
and in the like foyer of the building
which was i guess
you like that you're like
i have a word of the day calendar
uh
which was like
two stories four apartments two in the
floor two on top yeah uh came in there
was a spider crawling across the floor
and i took my foot wet these guys he
spawned took my foot
put it down on him and it crunched and
the loudest crunch i've ever heard from
a spider i've never heard of spider
crunch it was an army and it went crunch
and i was like that was really weird
yeah and as i slowly picked up my foot
hundreds of baby spiders
it was an egg like we had an egg sack in
the back that i stepped on and i just
[ __ ] oh my god oh i had to move
because they were now and now the baby
spiders are on the first floor on the
second floor they're eventually going to
learn and then you moved out right and
then you said you said you torched the
place and then you i told everybody
you've got to get out i just ran house
to house just screaming
james on youtube said spider-man 3 is my
worst spider story
very nice good job
they say that a hero
i know it's not spider-man 3 but it
always makes me
yes um they had a
desktop screen saver for that spider-man
and they would play that song over and
over again but just that part of it and
i had it on my computer and just to like
kind of mess with my siblings
but yeah i eventually learned to love
that song
strangely enough
someone said is the patch out yet yes it
is this is the cash this is the patch
you are looking at the patch so you can
get this right after the stream if you
are still playing shut the hell up
that's what we're playing
is the mass effect trilogy wait the mass
effect trilogy is worth playing if you
haven't yet yes we agree
check it out 100 yeah and you can
probably get it pretty cheap on steam
i think i got um the first two and
seemed really cheap for like eight bucks
or something like
a month or two ago
just to have
game looks kind of great on pc consoles
too to be honest
yeah we did a graphics comparison for
this game and i really could not tell
much of a difference
like obviously pc is going to look the
best but there wasn't too much of a
difference
that i can tell
what did you think of it on ps4
it was i mean it didn't it didn't look
as good as pc that was my takeaway but
it's also that that's the problem with
pc yeah where i did the preview event
played it and it was like all right cool
this looks good but like i have no idea
of this pc overclocked and the teraflops
and the what you know i mean so then to
get it at home like well this doesn't
look as good but no big deal and then it
was like oh well the eyes are weird oh
man why are those guys just walking for
no reason man all the animations are
screwed up what is this
suggestion on youtube play andromeda
first trilogy will be even more amazing
that reverse order
or four then one two three sure
that's the new order for playing mass
effect
and just like that we're going to show
off his laptop
yes
look out
are your teammates doing a little bit
better this time around are they just
standing there you know they're getting
the phone i was just like oh
room and then lay it on and then they
were like you know what no yeah guess
what this orb is gonna come coming right
back
it's one of those moments in a boss
fight you're like what am i missing
something important here
twitch said i thought they hate this
game we do not hate this game there are
multiple you gave it you gave it a 60
which means personality we can all have
different opinions on the scale of six
to ten that means you think it's
horrible and you think it's the worst
editors are in office you know how many
producers are not because we all have
different opinions
so we'll review this one so scott
butterworth reviews no he's the worst
i love you scott
uh let's see any questions over on
youtube and twitch right now
i wonder how uh kind of funnies chad is
doing right now let's see if you look at
this tell me what the kids are saying
the best friends
someone says which is amazing hell yeah
it is dr box said that
mario kart incoming hype [ __ ] yes oh my
god mario kart yes i cannot wait to play
mario kart 8 deluxe
all right um you're gonna play that on
your wii u too come on i need a second
game that i actually want to play on the
switch before i buy this one mr shifter
one two graceful explosion machine today
come on now
i'm just i'm done fine i'm behind on the
times
greg i love your vita island thank you
oh that's nice
now this is a fun from your chat on
youtube dreamcast guy says greg is
trolling hard lowell i love that
dreamcast guy he
i love that dreamcast guy i love that
doing great said sanchbear hello thank
you very much all right shout out to
sanshbear for playing all over the place
there's amy gills too they're all that's
those are i know people from my channel
hey guys i don't think this isn't
showing
this is my chat but then there's both
chats nice interesting
oh all right let's look at this anime
we're using some biotics here what's
this cut scene right this wouldn't help
at all yeah
i don't think this is different right no
cutscenes i don't think cutscenes have
not been fixed well i don't think they
were were they broken i guess
brenston buckner mass effect drama is my
favorite to play in the series two and
three are better games to me but as far
as
gamepl actually an insult i guess to an
artificial but it doesn't feel stiff i
always thought that mass effect did feel
stiff to a certain person yeah someone
said worth starting the game or wait for
future patches that's totally up to you
that's your preference what are you
playing right now yeah if you have
nothing to play right now i'm sure
but if
[Music]
after this cut scene we will show off
this fine laptop that we are playing on
which i'm sure you're all very curious
about we've actually gotten a couple
questions about it and her final moments
won't be lost it's small which i like
your pathfinder
video games can be so divisive man ain't
that the truth it's almost like we just
tear apart the things we love
they want to argue about them
like why somebody would play a game on
the wii u because they when there's a
better system
out right now
just do that
get ready for car you're gonna be able
to find it for cars
you're never going to be able to keep
things right
yeah we do tear apart the things we love
like my biggest issue was that hit movie
the boss baby is called the boss baby
and not just the boss baby or that it
just exists
why doesn't it exist right why is it
doing so well
it's
the number one movie in the country and
that means they'll probably get a secret
oh yeah sorry oh yeah i came up with uh
but then scott bromley
one up to me and said that it would be
called uh terrible twos
instead boss baby terrible twos yeah
that's you pretty good that's pretty
good one of your hairbrained ideas got a
shark kill
they do look better i had to be sure
they do look better and we did
actually and again
this is just a cut scene so you can't
tell the difference but when they are
talking to answer your question yes
the lip syncing does look better
who's next in line
pay this woman hollywood
should be out there titling sequels
[Laughter]
thank you maybe a pathfinder with some
humility
can do better
you can look one of my main problems was
the asari have all the same facial
models
that's their race man that's that makes
you already look like that's the problem
you have so you can't tell them apart
playing thomas it's okay it's totally
fine they all look the same to me
all right so it's about that time so uh
before we
keep it i'll take it keeps orisa where
she is
you can't be serious
you can't afford to lose a pathfinder
with her power and experience that's
true
it's true you can't handle the truth
people down again i'll do
my job a tundra
and i'll take the consequences
can you tell him
yeah
that's the one with the thing on her
face and the other one didn't have
things on her face that's right dude
that is exactly right without
forgiveness
on youtube and twitch
if you have any questions for greg about
mass effect andromeda or if you have
questions about this alienware 13 which
we're gonna show off in just a sec
after this scene here we go oh tempest
making its approach
oh default xander boss baby two baby got
back oh my uh damn that is good i think
i still win dude but that's really funny
yeah he's going he's not really funny
he's not using the business yet before
his wife i'm talking about business yeah
i'm serious but i do like
your name
i do like your title it's very good good
job
boss baby team baby we're just as lost
as we are
we're not lost we know our mission i
think we're finding our way pretty well
should have known better than to say
that to a pathfinder
if you're just tuning in this is the
patched version of a mass effect
andromeda so if you can tell
female writer's got a little bit of life
in her face now so that's nice
their eyes look a little bit better
and the lip syncing has improved i
always look for the mentor their plan
as a path someone randomly said i hate
sword games
i don't know what the context was
they're making a good point all right
dude games are better than sword games
fact
dylan says the eyes still look bad
though their eyes their eyes do not move
as fluid
and as my friend
i hope that counts for something
everything now brenston buckner back
here nice to share comments with you
again greg i haven't seen you since i
screamed beyond at you a few years ago
i do a live show every day sir yeah you
can come by anytime anytime really talk
to me then you cannot run it he's all
over the internet dude what did you
he said something like that once still
true
i need to think of it but i'll be okay
here's something else i'll put out there
yeah that is not going to go over well
but i want you to know i like the
andromeda initiative initiative logo
better than the n7 logo
just set it just set it up there it's a
better color scheme as well
n7 doesn't mean anything
ai and andromeda initiative i get it you
know what i mean
all right sure all right so okay so now
let's show off this laptop so we've been
playing on pause this for just a second
because we're going to show off this
laptop right here there it is take a
look at the alienware 13 this is
the first
vr 13-inch laptop from alienware it's
very very nice what do you think of it
me yeah
i mean so far so good yeah i like that
it's small i was looking at all the
ports you got over there they got a lot
of ports in this lots this is just
really good b-roll you guys shot this
yes we did he has an aficionado of
b-roll
so it's got an oled anti-glare display
overall balance of performance and size
vr ready capability via nvidia geforce
gtx 1060 now with 7th gen intel kb lake
cpus for improved performance and
battery life over previous generations
it feels tough dense and rigid it's i
think it's definitely a premium product
and it supports alienware's external
graphics amp technology i'm lifting it
up yes yeah oh well there's they're
looking yeah it's nice i know they're
not saying i'm doing my own testosterone
it's very important you brought me in to
play the game lift it up now they can
see you there you go look guys look how
light it is it's very weak see
we have no upper body strength and here
i am carrying it
yeah oh look at you yeah look at all
right wings well let's jump back into it
we're now playing the game all right
cool back of the game all right cool now
back to my argument here though about
the ai versus the n7 a lot of people a
lot of people not happy with that yeah i
don't think i don't think people are
happy now i think you're gonna piss off
a lot of people well i just got it
somebody's got to say it somebody yeah
i'm not going to be
scared to come out and say that the a
the andromeda initiative logo better
than the n7 logo and seven's in military
ring somebody tosses out there well that
makes even less sense because it's
plastered on everything
you know what i mean you see it
everywhere are you just sick of it
because you just see it all the time
right this could be a big part of it
there could be a big part of it i didn't
get into mass effect and tell a mass
effect 2. yeah so that's my thing am i
loading a new game or what are we just
going to keep playing uh do you want to
keep did we finish this mission we did
we're back on the tempest here we're
chilling out let's go let's travel to a
different galaxy or a different place
go to the galaxy map and yeah yeah
let's see
that change and how you can now skip
those autopilot sequences i like the
galaxy map
now he uh you want to know best girl in
this game yes tell me who best friends
have a problem i got a crush i was
running some numbers mass balances and
stuff she looks a little better she's my
lady all right okay and that's saying
something because she still doesn't look
good she was
just very
her eyes there was just something dead
there i don't i don't know what was
happening but she looks like a woman
mechanically but something heavy and
unexplained that's not good
our internal sensors someone in the chat
asked how much the laptop was the answer
is it starts at 999.99
which rounds up to a thousand i know
a lot of people ask me about the
teraflops
there's a lot of teraflops inside of
this
13 from what i understand
um
i heard that there is more teraflops
inside if there's a lot of terraflops in
the alienware 13. the xbox scorpio has
maybe not as much as the the airline
with 13 teraflops but it has more
teraflops on the playstation 4 pro and
all that means that your video games
will still give you differences to [ __ ]
about it it's awesome so we're not we're
just going out we're just going to go
see you let me just jump around yes
let's travel cluster map yes because now
here we go you can skip those autopilot
sequences over here you have to deal
with that anymore
let's see if it lets you skip
i'm clicking buttons trying to skip
casey are the rumors true
i was trying to skip at the wrong part
because i remember this being a lengthy
process that i did not enjoy when i was
playing because there's there's two
sequences right
when you go to a planet
i'll see
that's my same logo
well i'm here now it says
they've added the option to skip the
autopilot sequences in the galaxy map
oh do i is it an option like maybe i
should turn off
oh there it is okay haha it works
there you go we're there quicker
you're there faster you're saving so
much time all right well now we're
activating this ah
where would you like to go next greg
right here to landing zone
hdrc you want to go do this thing do the
thing i don't know whose mission is
we'll figure it out we'll find out we're
jumping in burke says greg do you play
your vita anymore i do play my video
once in a great while now
i play once in a while but i put it down
because persona 5's out on ps4 that's
that's what you got to do now you can of
course use remote play to play yours
yeah but that hasn't been helping me
because i've been wanting to watch
netflix will i chill out but then i
can't be watching netflix on the ps4 and
then do i want the xbox and the ps4 on
together no probably not
not at the same time
not at the same time
why does there's no this man has
what do you guys want to see us play in
the game let us know over on the chat
we're on youtube and twitch tell us
where to go
and we might just listen to you i'm
loading up the shotgun that's what we're
gonna do very nice we're gonna go out
there and kill some stuff
onto which someone said you saved one
whole second
not necessary
all right
all right here we go
i can skip this too see oh
look at all this
the scourge didn't you don't have to do
that
we have to walk skip it oh no yeah
i want to hear what this guy needs
traveling
this is new to us there she is everybody
there she is
look at that hair
how good are these fancy suits if they
don't block radiation i like that she
doesn't brush her hair she just probably
does this in the morning i'm sure and
then she goes she's a pathfinder she
doesn't need to i feel like they got to
save water
that's true
also you should only wash your hair
every few days not every day
that's what dry shampoo is for
engineering hot tip good luck you're
welcome
really i shouldn't wash my hair every
day not every day use dry shampoo on the
second day even me
it's not like just a girl thing like
long hair thing everyone really yeah
because a long time ago fran mirabella
at ign blew my mind because he told i
was telling him like conditioned every
day and he's like don't what are you
talking about no conditioning twice a
week maybe
he's got something he's got the best
hair so clearly he would know but i
didn't happy now i'll be happier jorge
said is this the 1.5 patches it's a 1.05
patch and that is what you're looking at
right now we just got it right before
this stream started
gravity's lower than we're used to
pathfinder
about accidentally hitting escape
velocity someone said those seconds add
up when you play for 45 plus hours
that's true so that will save you time
so being able to skip those scenes you
finally check on your child in the other
room
child
what
yes you had a child don't you remember
craig do you think your switch will
replace your ps4
no
if i mean if honestly i've talked about
it if like when mass track was coming
out yeah i was like if switch could run
mass effect that would be that would be
a game changer yeah and i would like if
persona could be on switch in the same
way if it could be on vito or whatever
perfect
[Music]
is this fairly open
this area that we're in yes very nice
very nice
it's a
not not a lot going on here why did you
just find a new plan yeah i'm going to
this thing see what's going on over here
you know what's that i don't know that's
where we're going to find out this is
what it's all about discovery we are
discovering let's see what's going on
discovered crater
you should be able to exit the nomad
once inside
what about the crazy space radiation
structure space radiation the crazy
space radiation
someone said what world is this
uh i thought it was some crater thing
yeah
that's pop here it'll tell me right no
does it say
matt uh yeah we're on h047c
catchy name
i left my shotgun behind i'm sorry i
left my sniper rifle behind for the shot
no because i was like yeah i didn't even
need that one
and for those of you just checking in we
are playing mass effect andromeda and we
are on youtube and twitch if you've got
questions for greg let us know over on
youtube and twitch and we will relay
those questions to him or he'll read
them straight off the screen i'll do
what i want yeah he'll do you guys don't
you don't own me no
today we don't only knicks garpino does
make sure you know
got it got it
all right i like the shotgun a lot
at first i was like i should run the
snipes
now i'm doing fine
that's pretty sweet i like that
[Laughter]
and when there is you'll just shoot up
the memorial exactly well that's uh
when you visit his planet memorial
was that like a bed what was that
memorial that they had earlier it was a
creepy it looked like they were trying
to bring the person back to life it
didn't look like a memorial as much as
the resurrection of
hail satan were going to bring the
person back
to be the destroyer of the world
much too excited any glitches so far we
haven't seen any wealth you've been
playing right yeah i don't think i've
seen anything
i don't know if the patch fit fixed that
or we just didn't go to an area with
much glitchiness
all right zagger in this chat but from
my chat as well he says hey greg nick
says you need a haircut and you should
come with him to do with the barber
today i need a haircut my plan is to get
it while right after this i'm going to
go home i'm going to eat lunch then i'm
going to go back to my neighborhood my
hood get it nick goes and gets fancy
haircuts he had a call yesterday make an
appointment i'm not about that life i
just walk into mine pricey fancy
haircuts i don't know probably nice
seems like one of the fancy boys
he's getting the beard trim too oh
is there a morning show today on kind of
funny yes yes right after this 11 a.m
twitch.tv
there you go
gameplay versus graphics which matters
more
well gameplay yeah i mean that's the
whole thing like mario i would say it
doesn't look great right but it's still
that's what you want to play
yeah i'm playing zelda and wii u and i
don't care because of the gameplay
gameplay is great
how are the changes like improved lip
sync and facial acting and the creepy
eyes are they really any better yeah we
saw slight improvements in that and
you'll see that
more if we interact with
some somebody that said let's go back to
uh
uh the arc not the arc you know what i
mean the um tempest yeah to get to the
place where you go to the nexus nexus so
we can go to the nexus we'll go talk to
some people we'll see what's happening
up there yes we're abandoning shipping
cool we killed these people
we showed up ruin these people's lives i
have no idea why i shot them
no idea
now over there colin e suchland says
also shout out to the columbia daily
tribune which was my job before ign so
that's yes shout out to them nice my
first job out of college maybe he's
catching up on the spider story exposure
to the surface radiation will kill you
pathfinder back to the tempest
extraction progress every door greg why
don't you grow a beard like nick
i'm you know
the problem is that the beer will look
so bad for so long
that before
can you grow a nice beer i don't know
like because you let it go long enough
and then it's just like this weird
stubbly
you know five o'clock shadow forever
yeah no that's the life i want i'm on
camera every day i shouldn't be doing
that probably
yeah that's true
if you're just tuning in we are playing
for another half hour this is mass
effect andromeda and we are playing the
new patch patch 1.05 and we're playing
this thanks to our friends over at dell
gaming and we're playing on the
alienware 13 gaming laptop
and you've got questions
give them to us on twitch and youtube
and we'll try to answer them for you
talk about mass effects talk about
whatever you're playing talk about
persona we love talk about personality i
love talking
crap it's been so long how do i remember
where the next is
it's been too long
we gotta go back
so do this there you go
choose a mission
i'm sick of this cough i got you know
what i mean it's just this like annoying
little cough
been lingering for weeks
no it's just over the weekend that it
popped up and i was like oh i feel like
i'm getting sick and then it's been like
a thing where i was like okay i was
stuffy one day okay now i'm this and
then today's thing is like you're gonna
cough a little bit allergies are really
bad this season and that's what i can't
figure out it started when i was in
austin it's like is it an allergy thing
or is it that i'm it's both
it's good definitely an allergy thing
too pretty sure
let's didn't do what i wanted to at all
they told me so it's like greg beard no
thanks keep it clean sir
plenty of beards at the office they're
actually injured
[Laughter]
chad i remember how to get to the nexus
help them out chat
i i put down
i chose the mission life on the frontier
i thought that would drop it right on it
why does that sound familiar is there a
is there a is there a terminal i have to
go to and hit the buttons to reach the
citadel give greg some tips over on chat
we're on youtube and twitch
tell them where to go the goddamn nexus
it's the nexus of the universe
penguin von penguin says greg stop
smoking
i do think that has something to do with
it i had to smoke a cigarette the other
day to keep us from getting in a fight
with the guys across the street oh okay
and so it was a peaceful
exactly
a peacemaking it was like a peace
pipeline yes exactly
i brought them beers and they were like
well no smoke the cigarettes
i didn't say that i don't smoke
and i just i just did this you know you
just do what i had to do
the orange text is where you need to go
thank you missed it i'm an idiot it was
right there very big who said that
thank you so much thank you
um i think
david burke in there said it was there
if they asked if there was an update on
p.s i love you xoxo because we went on
hiatus when colin left i want to figure
out what i want to do with it still
kicking around ideas and i know i've
been saying that for a while but it's a
big decision for me me and tim have been
talking about nick too obviously but
mainly tim because you know nick's
always off doing something stupid i'm
gonna eat this cough drop by the way
but just the idea we're working on and
when i say tim i don't mean to take the
other seat yeah i have a call today with
somebody about it too i'm working on it
i'm thinking about things
trying to figure out what i want to do
i'll say this
you'll get at least one more episode
but i'll leave it at that for right now
you heard it here you've got more
questions let us know and we'll try to
answer those but yes you were looking at
the newly patched mass effect andromeda
i can skip i can
save seconds of time by skipping through
these sequences go to my document there
you go
guys for someone who has never played
these games is it the right time for me
to get
up this game after the patch
to get into the game after the patch uh
yeah
sure now
yeah why not that's totally up to you
you can wait for more what do you think
of looking at it
yeah make an assessment from what you
see here
are you into mass effect
and as just in theory
does this appeal to you do you like
sci-fi do you like spaceships if so yeah
sure jump in it's totally up to you you
can also wait for more patches i would
like to welcome if you waited this long
sure keep waiting
lots of games to play right now had a
long journey but we're thrilled
department has finally arrived we ask
for patience as we find homes for
everyone
to those who doubted the future
the proof stands before you the asari
lives see this is the thing like even in
the you know
10 12 15 hours i forgot what i ended up
stopping when i stopped playing there's
how i'd already come around in his
character
like hating him and then kind of liking
him but i mean he's douchey
[Laughter]
someone said can you skip docking take
off animations too or just world to
world jump director tan said
the dream i think some of you could
because when we were coming in the
second time right
this time
exactly what i would have said
in fact i think i did
we
why colin don't believe in god
there are there's a conversation with
colin and a game over greggy about it so
you can
find out
i just like the way the question okay i
like how you ask that i like the
phrasing
why don't believe in god i am
i owe you everything
if it hadn't been so what has the update
changed look at their faces can't you
see look the eyes are different the lip
syncing is different the zigzag run is
different you can see the zigzag runs up
in the beauty now we're going to show
you that zigzag it's like dion sanders
out there yeah dude it's great uh
single-player balance changes ammo
crates armor weapons nomad profiles
attack and progression multiplayer
balance changes and weapons covering
enemies improved tutorial placement
increased inventory limits
added option to skip the autopilot
sequences in the galaxy map as we just
showed you before
decrease the cost of the remnant
decryption keys improve logic timing and
continuity for relationships and story
arcs
various collision issues which greg was
very excited about can't wait yup yup
so all sorts of things there's full
patch notes out there those are just a
few things your youtube comments penguin
von penguin another one of our fans see
sorry do look different that one was
purple the other one was brown totally
different
[Applause]
love it
[Music]
and now we're on little shuttle yep
something said the game is so weird the
animations look three or four years old
yeah
mass effect animation has never looked
cutting edge yeah what you gonna do
take off your rose called a glass
zigzag did you do that i was i was
exaggerating
that's
i found something while monitoring comms
for the nexus
multiple attacks whenever i see these
people they make me miss uh
they're hitting outposts and supply
vessels
that's so fantastic
like
in the past games there were definitely
the characters that you
are so memorable and that you just
gravitate towards not so much here yet
for me
in this game and they say they'll
investigate i like people a lot but it's
cool
friend of the show
i didn't know that when i was when i was
falling in love with her i didn't even
know she said she just changes her voice
so much i can't tell
i had no idea
operations wait look at the little biker
gloves you got your rider also look at
her leg twist she's like very impatient
like whatever's doing
she got time for this dude
but i got the nav points for the most
recent raids
maybe the tempest scanners can figure
out where they went
if you guys have questions about video
games in general or life or whatever
we'll do your relationship advice yeah
relationship advice ask those questions
on youtube and twitch because you've got
greg here for another
20-ish minutes and then the kind of
funny morning show yeah dude over at
twitch.tv
and we are playing this on the alienware
13 thanks to dell gaming
oh someone's never seen the game before
they said this is my first time seeing
the game it's actually very pretty
there you go
first impressions
first impression of someone seeing it
post patch
jason said pb is the best yeah
so boyle should i finish mass effect 3
before starting andromeda yes
what have you been doing for like a
decade
[Music]
finish it dude and then jump into this
because then maybe there will be a patch
another one when i screw up
screwed up
didn't go right flat please screw it up
everybody my apologies
that's okay i did it that was something
it's okay
stephen barr says hey greg why aren't
you fat anymore i am still fat sir
everybody's so caught up
i'm not fat i'm fat
i want this pizza pizza
pizza all right now how can it be in
this something's going on here
we got some fishy business here what is
happening how can you keep sending me
back to the same place over and over
again
groundhog day dude no
life on the frontier
investigate the space attacks
science investigation okay okay
what are you talking about sites
investigated zero four investigate space
attacks so i forgot on the nexus ships
that's what it seems like
you can also see what's happening with
the fire oh that's done that's no oh
protesters all right sleeping drags
let's talk to them instead
mm-hmm that works
sleeping dragons
i love a good protest
i'm sorry lana they're just trying to
push them around
this guy there we go
don't like the kind of video yes dude
i love that expression andy b says greg
how's the persona 4 plaque coming you
can go to hell
you know i i bought goldfarb and steiner
the pizza they deserved
i knew i was wrong i was wrong
i need to talk to you about stasis
revival and those protesters and
hydroponics
i see
maybe i should get the other i think
this game just
everyone's pretty divided on it
is what it seems like they want their
families outside everyone's not in one
camp or the other they're like
destructive there are people that do
love this game
and it's the same problem as anything
else like yes colin said his argument
all the time the protesters when people
would announce uh like when the batman
arkham knight dlc season pass got
announced right yeah and they didn't say
anything about it we don't have the
reason i was as a player of batman
arkham knight like all right cool
whatever i'm just gonna buy it out and
mix i know they're gonna be great yeah
and then colin was like that's stupid
dlc is broken down i was like you were
never going to play this you're not the
audience for this when the mass effect
andromeda gifts start coming out
suddenly everyone gets the impression
that the game's terrible and so even if
you were never going to play mass effect
you now think the game's terrible and
you have an opinion on it i think that's
part of it don't wrong game's not great
it's not mass effect 2
but of course suddenly everybody hates
or does whatever like before you even
went live the stream was thumb down a
whole bunch because oh mass effect mass
effect
we only just got on our feed plus it
messes up the schedule again
they seem sympathetic but so did the
exiles we've got to play persona grey
survival is more important trust me
we
[Music]
i don't ever agree with tan and stuff so
i'm going to say no protesters are right
these people aren't the enemy we didn't
come all this way to rip off the kai
kawasu said great pockets full of soup
episode chastity oh thank you so much
and you were on there too you were the
very first episode i was i was yeah i
learned a lot about you it was a good
show thank you
i love that jerry petty
he's such a good dude
one of the best humans
okay so what are we what are we up to
we're gonna go authorize some revivals
all right
let's do it
we've got about 20 minutes left i think
we'll have enough time to revive these
guys sounds good
and so you guys have 20 minutes to get
your questions in if you want to ask
greg anything about anything in general
pizza
persona
i was at the blouse in hydroponics and
he got run over by a space car run over
by a spacecraft
i'm glad it's time
i know exactly what you're feeling my
family has suffered too i wonder if her
brother's awakening
my mom was scared something would go
wrong and she'd be awake and stasis all
that time
she isn't
it doesn't work like that but i
just want her out so i know i understand
i understand
stasis revival triggered on the nexus
for jasper k
griffith g
hilqvist a dimension we're reuniting
sometimes oh that's nice yes that's her
go appreciate this sounds really cool
i'm a single go find your boss you know
we're nicer than that appreciate this
appreciate i did this for you we're
nicer than that thank you
was she commanding to him to appreciate
you understand what i've done for you
do you know the value of my actions
when it's time you'll have a home
wingstop or buffalo wild wings
really yeah
yeah i've
i'm usually happier at a buffalo wild
wings but some i've been to some really
good wing stops though see i think i've
had just mediocre wingstop experiences
so often but in wild wings you go in you
can sit down that lemon pepper though
true true ain't gonna knock that yep
if i eat pizza and play persona will i
achieve enlightenment and transcend my
humanity yes that's a fantastic question
answers yes you unlock the power within
you
i am val and vow our time
persona persona
i love how someone's asked who your
favorite persona was and you answered
like so specifically about persona in
the game
deep dish thin or regular oh man it
depends on my mood but i usually go
new york pizza slice like standard
yeah right that's what you gotta do
regularly as a chicago man they don't
expect me to argue that you know you
should eat chicago pizza every day yeah
you can't do that that's not how it
works exactly even in chicago that's a
special occasion pizza that's not i'm
eating that every friday every friday
we're having fin crust or you know what
i mean
regular
a slice as they would say in new york
just a slice
is the situation nobody cares leave me
yeah don't stop talking a woman i know
i'm doing something over here what do
you guys think of this
patch let us know in the chat and what
do you think of pizza tell me what's
going on in the chat italian thin crust
someone said
yeah
remember when you were growing up and
like going to the olive garden the
macaroni grill was like fancy i hate the
macaroni why do you hate it i don't know
i've always had drama at the macaroni
yes tell me some of the drama you've had
at the macaroni um i witnessed a breakup
um i had i saw members of my family
fight really hard at a macaroni grill i
got in a fight with a friend and a
macaroni girl and then we talked didn't
talk to each other for a couple years it
was intense i don't know what it is
about that place
maybe it was that particular macaroni
drip already grilled oh yes the same one
that one's cursed yeah i think it's
cursed
that one's out on long island i can only
think i've gone to the macaroni girl
once and it was for freshman year
homecoming and like that we thought that
was like fancy and one of the kids one
of the guys there but he's obviously a
kid freshman in high school yeah wanted
macaroni cheese and they don't serve it
there and so they made it for him though
because i'm sure they get that all the
time nice that is very kind of them all
right well maybe there aren't bad
macaroni girls i'm sorry i had such a
bad you just had it you ever cursed one
i understand that i went to the cursed
one
someone said pineapples are amazing on
pizza oh here we go here we go we
stumbled into this thing no no i'm not a
i'm not a pineapple on pizza guy but i
mean this is a community civil war we've
had for a long time joey noel our
community manager leading the war
against it
pineapples on pizza where do you stand
let us know in the chat i personally
love pineapples on pizza and i know that
i would disappoint many people in saying
that but i think it's just
i like pineapples in general
formula
domino's or pizza hut huh really come on
same
can you just go to a local pizza joint
difference
can we go back in time to one little
caesars
someone's just trolling now tuna and
banana pizza is the best get out of here
people are monsters
do you remember those just like square
pizzas that you would get in the
lunchroom at school they're just i swear
for no reason because they're probably
easier and cheaper to move that way
exactly
i do like pizza bites i like pizza
babies oh piece of makeup come on yeah
yeah that's good food in the middle of
the night yeah
now ronaldo says dang greg miller looks
old i used to watch him when he did
those oreo reviews in simcity
playthroughs thank you i'm tired of
being told all the time i'm a baby face
and this that and the other i've always
finally matured i have all this yeah i'm
assuring you
you have passed puberty
congratulations congratulations greg
miller thank you thank you you're a
mature man now
oh there's some pineapple love in the
chat i see two people who also love
pineapples
you don't want that you don't want to be
on their side at all or whatever bacon
pizza
bacon pizza
someone said i missed square pizzas you
know what i would eat a square pizza
right now we're getting pizza right
because now it's happening i swear
there's so much talk about pizza i think
there's a pizza place over there
i think i know what you're saying
i think i know what you're talking about
unless it's going out of business even
since then we'll find it
greg do you like the nolan north
impersonator doing the writer voice
i do
i think he does an admirable job i i
like his voice acting i thought that
male writer did a lot better than female
writers
really yeah i guess that's true i i play
as a male writer the colors are stunning
someone said don't forget pizza rolls
that's true
totino's pizza room you can do anything
you want with peace is pretty great yeah
environmental temperatures are within
acceptable limits
we've got about 12 minutes left we are
playing the patched out mass effect
andromeda on the alienware 13. thanks to
our friends at dell gaming
so if you've got any last-minute
questions get those in
and we'll try to answer them for you or
you can join the great pineapple debate
on pizza
people just relying straight up in the
chat now so they're lying boyle says i
put strawberry jam on my pizza don't lie
don't lie don't make me don't come in
here with lies do you actually put
strawberry jam on your pizza
be honest school there's so much shout
outs for school lunch pizza so many
shout outs school lunch pizza
school lunch pizza
remember lunchables when they started
making pizzas yes
i don't know how i felt about those but
i ate them oh yeah we all ate them
because it was like pizza and it was not
good pete so i'm eating pizza pizza
outside the gates you're on your own but
in here you're safe
anyone violates the piece they have to
answer to me
everyone's talking about pizza now i'm
glad that i made all of you hungry
i did it well i just love that pizza
my pinned tweet is me dressed as a pizza
really yes well it's there's two
pictures and it's get a girl who can do
both and it's me and my silent cosplay
and me dressed as a pizza more
importantly
i've actually gotten way more comments
about the pizza i'm sure that i did
about the psylocke cosplay
shocking
who would have thought
pizza such a hit so i think i was
pepperoni pizza before so i think i
might go to fanime as a like a combo
pizza this year i'm i'm wondering what
kind of
toppings i should do but since it's such
a hotly debated issue chastity
underscore v on twitter everybody i'm
going to see these cosplayers pineapple
on my pizza
you will be you will be beaten in the
streets it might be a pineapple pizza
just to make people angry
oh let's get out of this place is weird
just because i like getting yelled at in
real life
not just on the internet so i'm just
going to put pineapples on my pizza you
want random people drunks on halloween
screaming doesn't they walk away
pineapples on pizza
is an abomination
and you are wrong i can't open my start
menu
so it's a mass effect and drama piece
that was on me that death was on me
that's not a good joke but i'm laughing
so hard
we have 10 minutes left in our stream
we're playing mass effect andromeda
we are playing with the new patch 1.05
we're going to tame the desert
maybe we in the desert
and before we go we're going to show off
this laptop one more time because it's
fantastic
the alienware 14.
what are you looking at that's cool dude
someone brought up barbecue sauce
um what i mean buffalo chicken amazing
more ranch
i like ranch ranch on pizza is good i
don't like it
i'll look where i want sorry wesley's
nicely demolition someone else said
andromeda lasagna
is it necessary to engage with this
individual i don't see how it shut up
sam please please yes let's just back
away slowly guys man i didn't know there
would be such a debate about pineapple
yeah you stumbled right into it my
hotbed issue here but i love it i heard
that little i just love it
i don't understand wow be careful around
he's got a brain chemical in males
that's bad news is he okay
is he okay
where do people stand on stuffed crust
is what's going on in the twitch charity
i do enjoy stuffed crust and like doing
it wrong it's the same i mean i eat it
yeah it's one of those things i don't i
go out of my way to order that kind of
pieces but i remember one of my distinct
memories of like i love my parents i
love mom i love my dad
that maybe they weren't raising me
correctly was when
every friday was pizza night and we
started getting a little season this
again but four little caesars was five
dollars little caesars used to be a
reputable pizza place we were getting
little caesars with cheese and pepperoni
in the crust and then crazy bread with
cheese pepperoni goodness and it was
amazing i am salivating talking about it
right now but i was like i don't think i
should be eating this every week nor i
mean if i am eating this every week
maybe i should be forced into doing some
kind of activity
but i didn't care and then here we are
that's right i don't know man that pizza
life that's all i'm saying
it is it is the best life from the nexus
stephen barr once ordered stuff crust
and it took up more of the pizza than
the toppings and then he says a dirty
word you dominos
i don't see a problem like i mean that's
what you wanted right why didn't you
just we're all the same that's the
chance that survival is to cooperate
don't see a problem that includes the
krogan
we've got seven minutes here and then
seven minutes to say
and then we roll it into another stream
right after this on game spot we're
doing um go to kind of funny games
either one whatever you want to go
wherever you want to see what tim and
amy cortez think of that their scorpio
good boys all around you can watch them
you can watch rob and peter playing more
zelda
on triforce
get it yeah yeah i got it t-r-y
i didn't get it until you spelled it out
that's cool good it's good i like the
audio logs you sent do you sound like
something bad is brewing but you've got
seven minutes to ask your questions
or keep talking about pizza
hey man
america 2009 greg now that invincible is
confirmed what other comic book would
you like to see on the big screen
dude i lost my mind of course if i
didn't miss the bowl that reaction video
if you haven't seen it
it's my amazing game over here it's
amazing yeah uh
what i don't know because i just never
thought that would even happen i never
even thought they would do that
so i don't know i mean beyond that
there's i mean paper girls would make a
good one probably still ongoing so it's
confusing
yeah saga but that's the problem is i
even i don't know i can't say that again
cause i was gonna say even invincible
but i want
you know the one i always want that will
never get kingdom come okay i would love
to see dc say you know what we screwed
up the continuity we're done with it
here's the movie this is really on the
line john hamm and superman thoughts on
joss whedon's background can't wait oh
my god that was like i mean as a huge
back row fan as a huge joss whedon fan
like that was what an announcement yes
please bring some fun and levity and
cool characters here we need right now
exactly exactly for dc
someone said i'm going to get pizza in
seven minutes so are we
we will be watching
so is the patch making things better
that's a good question to kind of wrap
up this stream so what did you think of
what you played i mean like we were
saying right the faces seem better like
i don't know i'm not i'm not an expert
but it does seem better the animations
seem a little bit better
um
yeah i'm
it's more mass effect but it does my
problem is it felt so stilted on
playstation 4 and now playing on pc i
know it's going to be different yeah uh
but from what i'm playing it it does
maybe it's lowered expectations to you
but overall i'm going to come back to
mass effect i am going to play this
i i i'm appreciative of what they're
doing and i do like the fact that they
are continuing to make changes and they
say that they're going to keep coming
back
what did you think
i think it was back last night yeah i
think it looks a lot better like in the
matter of one evening like it all kind
of like i because there were so many
scenes i was watching the talking and it
was just getting to me because i like
they all looked dead in the eyes and
like the lips were off and so that's
improved and i'm glad that you can
finally skip in the map so you can save
some time
so i might jump back in now that the
patch is out yeah right you're gonna
keep playing persona but eventually one
day eventually i'm going i'm gonna say
maybe after persona
five percent
give one more zigzag
[Laughter]
all right so we are going to
wrap this up shortly and show off the
alienware 13 one last time so while
we're here on this screen let's cut to
b-roll
show that b-roll show that b-roll get
that b-roll up of the alienware 13.
there it is look at it it's beautiful
it's greens it sure does why don't you
tell them why it's not ladies and
gentlemen you of course are looking at
the alienware 13. let me tell you all
about it it's got that o-l-e-d like the
original playstation veto which was the
lander basketball the other vita it's
got anti-clear display overall balance
of performance and size it's vr ready
compatibility via nvidia g4 g force gtx
1060 and take it from me brother that is
a lot of g-forces and now with 7gen
intel kb lake cpus for improved
performance and battery life over
previous gen it feels tough dense and
rigid definitely a premium product it
supports alienware's external graphics
amp technology it's price starting at
999.99
and you can take it from me the man who
loves the playstation vita this is a
laptop it's a good one it's got a
screens and buttons and keys and it's
got a whole bunch of things on the side
yep
you got a mic input what was your
favorite thing about it
oh i mean to stop joking around again it
is i like for having having a gaming
laptop laptop that can actually do
real triple a games and make them look
this good usually they weigh a ton and
the batteries are huge and all this
different stuff and you saw in that
b-roll but i really like how the mouse
pad the touchpad lights up
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's real
nice yeah yeah like that and i like how
portable it is i think i can fit that in
the backpack i can carry it one-handed
it's quite nice yeah yeah good screen
good stuff
yeah let's peek at the game one more
time while we've got three
minutes left
two minutes left got some planets up
there so let's see what last minute
questions do we have we have two minutes
and i got two minutes to say anywhere
that's the thing you know kevin tim nick
they usually don't back me up on that
i'm glad i got you oh you got me
uh yeah tim said that i should come on
the show to talk about bsp versus nsync
and i will absolutely do that i remember
seeing a lot of feelings about we agree
100 on this
i have a lot of feelings okay
someone said oh lead yep that led's back
the oled
so after this stream you can check out
either one of the shows when kind of
funny or on game spot we've got a lot of
stuff to watch and then you can play
this patched out mass effect andromeda
if you liked what you saw maybe play it
on an alienware 13. maybe wait till you
get one of those
up to you
look at these stupid insane crabs look
at them
dummy aliens
any last-minute questions on kind of
funnies chat right now
we have one minute left the countdown is
on
um
there's something my chat here is still
talking about
pizza pizza yeah yeah good yeah the
eternal debate let us know what you
think about pineapple and pizza
greg where can they find you on twitter
can you find me a game over greggy on
twitter there you go and my pin tweets
me freaking out about him in school it's
really good and then you can find me on
twitter chastity underscore v and we can
talk about pizza some more if you want
tell me how mad at me you're going to be
when i put pineapple on my pizza cosplay
i thought pb was going to be in here i
thought we're going to end talking
all right we are wrapping up so let's
say goodbye to the good folks any last
second questions who would win in a
fight between backstreet boys are in
sync in sync probably really i don't
know that one is where i give it to
backstreet boys
no they're from the back streets they
are they are but i love nsync i love
instinct too but i just think that they
okay you know what the backstreet boys
are still doing stuff right now like
they're doing their vegas thing so they
would win because they are like in shape
right now so you're right all right
we're wrapping up
tossing it over to kind of funnies
morning show and also to gamespot
doing triforce so thank you for joining
us i'm chassis this is greg and this is
all brought to you by dale gaming so
thanks to dell gaming take care don't
screw this up kevin
[Music]
me